Speaker 1: I want to show you a very funny
short clip of Republican Senator Marco Rubio.
Rubio appeared on Fox News last night after
Joe Biden's State of the Union address.
And it is so funny what Rubio says.
I'm not even going to tease it for you.
Okay.
Let's just play it and then we will discuss.
Speaker 2: You didn't hear a lot of talk about
pregnant men tonight.
You didn't hear a lot of talk about some of
these crazy things because they're pivoting
now to an election mode and they know all
that stuff is toxic.
So try and pretend it's not happening, but
it remains at the core and at the heart of
their administration.
Not a lot of woke talk tonight except for
the climate stuff, which, by the way, he doesn't
tell you benefits China.
Speaker 1: Marco Rubio realizing in real time
Joe Biden didn't talk about pregnant men.
Joe Biden didn't talk about woke stuff.
He says it's because they're pivoting, pivoting
to election mode.
The reality is Joe Biden never was talking
about this stuff.
And in fact, these are very small issues on
the Democratic side, on the left, in the Democratic
Party.
I will not deny for a second that if you spend
a lot of time on Twitter or Reddit, you might
see a whole bunch of stuff about Wokeness
and so-called pregnant men and all of these
things.
I don't deny that you might see that if you
spend a lot of time on these platforms, but
if you spend a lot of time on those on those
platforms, you would have been one of the
people in 2020 who thought that Bernie had
the nomination wrapped up and that there was
no interest in Joe Biden being the nominee.
And as I told you then, as and as I will repeat
now, the discussions that dominate some of
these online spheres are not actually the
issues of greater concern to the vast majority
of the Democratic Party, nor of the constituents
of the Democratic Party either.
And there was a reason that you didn't hear
a lot about woke I'm sorry about pregnant
men last night, which is it's not actually
an issue that is at the forefront of the minds
of almost anyone on the left.
I would actually go even further.
Part of the reason that those sorts of things
even come up at all are because the right
has abandoned policy and only wants to talk
about that sort of thing.
It is because the right brings forward issues
of their putting cat litter boxes for furries
who are study of fur, be people who think
they're animals or they even know how to define
furry.
But that's not a real story.
But it is the right that creates the story.
It's the writers that they want.
Double mastectomies for pre-pubescent girls.
Wait a second.
Do they have breasts?
If they're prepubescent, that doesn't make
any sense whatsoever.
It's the right that is crow.
Barring a lot of these issues and none of
this stuff has ever been at the heart of the
Democratic Party.
And this is why looking at Twitter isn't super
useful to figure out what's going on in the
U.S. overall and what's going on within the
Democratic Party.
Maybe Marco Rubio is realizing that if you
want to see this clip, it's on our YouTube
channel, YouTube.com slash The David Pakman
Show.